- Hey gorgeous.
- Hey.
I was just gonna make a
video about my three looks,
my four looks.
When it goes to the thick eyebrow look,
thank you, Teresa Jones.
Who knows who the writers are?
My whole storyline, thank you so much.
Thank you so much.
I'm here.
Thank you guys so much.
Yeah, it's true.
Why would I be happy at the end?
That stupid song.
Thanks for the Mark visit.
Thank you guys.
- [Mark] All right, Lima and Larry.
We had Amanda's final
court hearing this morning,
which is a big day.
A couple of things in Amanda's future
were hinging on what the judge said today.
So fill us in on what happened, Lima?
- So originally as
discussed in the last video,
we were going for an LPS conservatorship.
And the purpose was to get
Amanda committed to a program
and to ensure that we
had power of attorney
to make the decisions for Amanda,
since she was not capable of
making decisions for herself.
So she was a prime candidate.
These conservatorships are
extremely difficult to get
because there's a lot of evidence
that needs to be demonstrated.
And Amanda had all of that checked off.
The issue with that was
that we were not able
to have communication between the jail
and the doctor at the jail,
but we had everything else on our end
with a second doctor referring it.
And so Amanda has a public defender.
As a public defender,
they have so many clients
that it's really hard for them to dedicate
the time required
to actually push something
like that through.
And so, because of the fact
that we didn't have anything
from the other end,
which was the jail side,
we weren't able to push the
conservatorship through.
So in the last 72 hours,
I've been trying to do damage control.
And I actually woke up at 2:30 a.m.
this morning to make sure that court
at 8:30 in the morning went fine.
And we diverted to put in a court order
for Amanda to complete
one year of treatment.
So she risks that if
she doesn't complete it,
she goes back to jail.
- [Mark] So Amanda today,
this is the first time
I've seen her in two months, I think.
Almost two months.
This was a totally different Amanda.
- Yes, this is the--
- I didn't even recognize her.
- This is the Amanda,
I called her Amanda Bear because
she's been quite responsive
and she's doing so much better
just being off the streets
and in an environment where
she's being controlled.
So I told her she's
doing the hard work now.
So any program that we place her in,
then she's gonna already have herself
prepared to participate.
So she has come along quite well
with the help of Lima and Mark.
It's just encouraging to
know that there's still
good-hearted people that will
step up to such a big at bat.
I mean, this is really big.
- [Mark] Yeah, Lima's been amazing.
- Thank you guys.
- She's detailed person.
I used to tell my troops,
pay attention to detail.
If I could have had her
picture on the example,
she would have been there.
- [Mark] I've never
interacted with somebody
who's so thorough and so buttoned up
about every single thing.
- Daily, daily.
- [Mark] And figuring out some way
to get around this loophole
and figure out the
solution to that problem.
And she just is, has been relentless.
- Exactly.
- And Amanda this morning was,
she was unrecognizable.
- Adorable.
- [Mark] She's put on about what?
15, 20 pounds probably.
- She looks like her old self.
- She walked into the courtroom and said,
good morning, your honor.
And she was respectful.
She didn't talk over people.
And the hardest part for
me to watch, this is long.
She was up there 15 minutes,
at least, 20 minutes.
The DA was reading her
off all this legalese
about how she potentially
could be going to prison
for three years.
And the fines could be
this and all these things
if she doesn't do things,
if she screws up with going to rehab
or she escapes or whatever.
And she handled it
perfectly all throughout.
She was so respectful and so calm.
It was hard to watch,
but she did a great job.
- Incredible.
- Yeah, absolutely.
I do think that it's
important to note that
even though all of the
documents were sent in file,
or that all of the documents on my end
were filled out and sent
and even the program
that I had Amanda accepted into,
nobody at the courthouse
actually had the paperwork,
even though it was emailed to them.
And so it's really important to note
that in cases where
it's a public defender,
there's a lot of people,
these are very short trials.
It's really easy to just
get lost in all of that.
So I think that it's really important
for other people out there
that are looking to do something like this
for their family member
to not just purely lean on the system
and expect that just because that person
has a representative,
that that representative
will do what it takes,
because it's not necessarily
that they don't care.
It's just that they're overworked.
And there's just so many people
that don't have resources.
- [Mark] I think you've
done most of the hard work,
in Amanda's case.
- Yeah, it's been really hard.
- [Mark] The rehab that Amanda's going to,
there were two options, right?
- So when I pitched the
idea to the courthouse
of Amanda going to a program,
what I did was I used the documentation
from the LPS conservatorship.
And so one of the documents is a one-pager
on Amanda's history.
And what that is is that I
worked with Larry to compose it.
And it details all of
her mental illnesses,
the diagnoses, her medical record,
like, just a very short summary,
jail time that she has done
and certain issues that
she's had in the past,
or even traumas.
And so super short one-pager
that shows the severity of the issue.
And we took that one-pager
and we pitched the concept
of being able to have
Amanda not do jail time
or not just be released on the street
where she's gonna end up
re-offending and in jail--
- [Mark] She would have been
free for 10 days, right?
- Not for 10 days.
She would have been potentially released
the last time I came.
So that last day that I went to court,
she was set to be released
back onto the street
because there were no
other options for her.
And so initially, when speaking
to the district attorney,
I notified her that this
was not Amanda's first time,
which was already
something that was known,
and that she's in a very bad mental state.
And so that was documented
on the one-page document,
because if you have
anything more than one page,
they don't have time to look at it.
And so based on that information
is what made them shift gears
and say that if we were
willing to take responsibility,
so basically myself,
willing to ensure that I report
everything to the courthouse
and make sure that Amanda
doesn't violate anything
and ensure that she follows court order,
that they would consider giving
her a mandated one-year plan
which would be the essential
path of an LPS conservatorship.
- [Mark] And she understood
it completely in court.
And she agreed to at all
with no one's coaxing.
She just said, yes, this is what I want.
- Yeah, and this is something
that Larry has been talking
to her for a while about.
So they talk daily and
I've been really surprised
that she's been actually
very excited about treatment
because I have to be careful
with what I say specifically
due to HIPAA law.
And I can't state anything
that is not already publicly known,
but one of the things that
we have been questioning
is Amanda's current diagnoses
from medical professionals.
And the reason for that
is because all of her,
the past seven facilities that she went to
were very short stays
and she was actually diagnosed
while using, exactly.
So it wasn't something that
we can really go off of.
And so now that she's been clean in jail
for the last two months,
we actually could have
had her transferred today,
but we chose to hold her
bed until October 10th
so that she knows for a fact
that this is not a right.
This is a privilege.
And that there are consequences,
that if she messes up,
she will go back to jail.
So we really want her to understand
that this is an opportunity for her
and she needs to take
full advantage of it.
And even though she's
saying that she's excited
for treatment right now and
that she really wants it,
we want her to be really
hungry for it when she gets it.
Because as you know, it's very expensive
and we've pulled a lot of
strings to make this happen.
The options from the courthouse,
when we pitched them the concept of Amanda
going to mental health care
for a year instead of jail
or instead of being released
and just being homeless again,
they have a court diversion program.
Those diversion programs can
have 100, up to 200 patients,
and you're not getting one-on-one therapy
and you're not getting the
necessary care that you need.
The program that Amanda
is gonna be going to
has seven patients, seven beds,
and it's intensive therapy
throughout the day.
And there's a lot of different activities
and they integrate
family therapy in there.
So then Larry will be
able to work with Amanda
- [Mark] And this kind
of care is expensive?
- Yes, yes.
- You don't have rehab
for seven patients for $1,000 a week.
It's expensive.
- Yeah, so before I continue,
I would like to state
that I am not a doctor.
I am not a lawyer.
So my advice should not be taken
in replacement for
medical or legal advice.
I'm just trying to share
information with people
because this is a lot of information
that has taken so many years to build up.
And it's just a lot more simple
when you actually know what to search for.
So the other factor is
that, can I talk about the,
I know you told me not
to mention the comments.
- [Mark] Oh, go ahead.
I mean, there's been
lots of negative comments
that don't understand what you're doing
or what you're offering
or what you're all about.
So if you wanna clarify that, please do.
- Exactly.
So I am the founder and
CEO of a tech startup
and we build technology software
for healthcare providers, mental health.
And the treatment centers
that we are sending Amanda to
are not owned by me and I
do not get paid by them.
So it's really important
to clarify that when,
in the past, when I've
said that the technology
that I provide facilities
to is evidence-based,
that means that it's
already been validated
and proven to work.
So we're not using anybody as a guinea pig
and we're not testing anything on anybody.
When I say that we're
providing the technology
to treatment centers
for research purposes,
those research purposes
are to demonstrate a value
to a treatment center.
So they're already making money
and they're already getting paid.
- [Mark] These are various, I mean,
the list of rehab facilities
that AURA works with
is an impressive list.
And you've already been working
with them long before you--
- So they're very
prestigious facilities that,
like I said, most people cannot get into.
And I personally cannot
afford those facilities
for my sisters.
And my sisters would be
Amanda price's times two.
So my initial initiative
for wanting to help Amanda
or wanting to objectively help someone
that I'm not related to,
that is basically to prove,
so what I'm trying to prove
here is not my technology
or it's not my,
it's initially that we
need long-term treatment
and we need additional
tools for therapists
so that they can measure
how patients are feeling.
- [Mark] And your company provides
those additional tools for therapists.
That's all.
- Exactly.
And so the facilities--
- [Mark] People had you, like,
I think you were performing lobotomies--
- No, not at all.
And the facilities that
ironically I work with
and that I supply this technology to,
I can't afford to send my sisters to.
So the goal is to really
make this scalable
and get access to it through insurance.
- [Mark] And it'll help
the world understand
how to treat these patients better.
- Exactly.
And then the last factor is
that I really do want to clarify
that all of the funds go to giving.org.
So I highly recommend people
to look into what Giving is
and who they are and who they represent,
because they've also represented
several high-profile charities
like Miley Cyrus's charity.
I can't remember the name of it.
But there's been several,
people should do the
research on who Giving is.
There's been a lot of
assumptions on who I am
and the fact that I'm not a real person
because my company was registered
under another last name.
That was my old last name.
I did get married recently.
So I am a real person
and a lot of speculation from people
that are not my clients
- [Mark] I mean, again,
YouTube just comments.
A lot of people just like
to create a controversy.
So, Larry, what's your
impression of what Lima has done?
- Lima has been tremendous.
She's been such a light in my life
because I was dealing with
Amanda all those months.
And I found out, in retrospect,
I didn't really know what I was doing,
but I had to do something.
So what Lima has done is brought to me
an organized plan for Amanda.
And that's what I never had.
I never had anybody say,
well, what are we gonna
do after we do this?
A conservatorship was
difficult, but there was a plan.
And she shared it with me.
And that's where we are now.
We're in the process of implementing it.
And her presence and her attention
to taking care of all of the things
that people don't pay attention
to has made a difference,
even today.
- She's been involved
in Amanda's life for how long?
Roughly a month or so?
There's been so much
progress in that last month.
More than in the last five years, right?
- Exactly.
And so when she said that
she's gonna help my family,
not just for now but
for some time to come,
that means everything to me.
- [Mark] Well, just seeing
who Amanda was today
this morning in court was--
- Incredible.
- [Mark] I couldn't, I
didn't even recognize her.
- Yes, she looked very good.
- [Mark] Is that the old
Amanda that you knew?
- That's Amanda Bear.
That's her.
- It's also pretty interesting
that Larry is a veteran
and his insurance is covered by the VA.
And Amanda actually should
be covered by the VA
and half of the costs
that we're trying to raise
on GoFundMe for her right now
should actually be completely
covered under insurance,
but due to loopholes
and certain things that
Larry was unaware of
to file for his daughter,
it's run its course.
And for example, there's TRICARE,
which I'm still trying to figure out
because for some reason
they're not covering Larry
but we're unsure of why.
And then the second option is CHAMPVA.
And so Amanda is completely dependent
on Larry for everything.
And before your child turns 18,
which this was happening to
Amanda before she was 18,
there's something that you can file
which is helpless child status.
And had Larry filed it,
we would have no problem
covering Amanda's care.
So because of that, it's been
extremely challenging for him
to provide any type of support
even though he did serve his country.
He's 60% disabled from his
service, and he's not able to,
he has to watch his daughter struggle
and die in front of him
without being able to cover
her treatment costs.
And navigating the VA is
a totally different thing.
But if you are a veteran
and your child has mental health issues,
I highly recommend that
before they turn 18
to ask about helpless child status.
- [Mark] Larry, tell me
about Amanda's childhood.
So tell me about Amanda's mother.
- Amanda, her mother's a beautician.
She's very busy and
successful at what she does.
So when I met her, I
was just a workaholic.
So it was a lot of fun times.
We got along very well.
Matter of fact, we met at an NBC sitcom.
We were just out in Burbank
going in to see a TV show.
So after that, we got along well,
and as a result, Amanda was born.
But even during our courtship,
I didn't get along with her
because she had a different personality,
like Jekyll and Hyde.
So I dealt with that
before Amanda was born.
But after Amanda was born,
I saw how it was affecting Amanda.
So I decided Amanda was
only about 10 or 11 months.
I said, I gotta make a change.
I gotta do something different.
And I just went and talked to
someone about going to court.
So I took custody of
Amanda at three years old.
So since then, I just raised Amanda.
I did my retail business
and raised Amanda until now.
- [Mark] And Amanda's mom was in her life?
- She was not in her life.
After we got the legal
custody and control,
she just disappeared.
So Amanda and I just
moved on with our lives
from elementary school on through
the University of Northridge.
We just had a good life.
I relived my life through her childhood.
So I must say, I know
Amanda had a lot of fun
'cause I did everything
that I could possibly do
when I wasn't at the store
trying to make a living.
So I told Amanda, I said,
I know people say you're spoiled.
I said, but we have to do
things to balance our lives.
I'm always working and
we have to do those.
So that's what we did.
Every year we went to all the places,
Knott's Berry, Disney
Land, the county fair.
That was the most interesting thing,
to turn her on to animals,
because city girls,
they know animals but to
see them and touch them
and maybe ride on, that was
the biggest thrill of her life.
So I'm sure if she would remember,
she would remember Knott's Berry.
So I just say to you,
Amanda enjoyed her life.
I spoiled her as a single parent.
As a retail guy, she
was always at the mall.
She was always getting stuff.
I mean, that's what I did.
That's my living.
- So she had a good childhood?
- She had a great childhood.
- [Mark] Excellent.
Well, today was a great day.
Amanda's got, her birthday is Sunday.
She's got about 10 or 15 days
before she gets taken from jail to rehab
for one year exactly, right?
- Yes.
Thank God Miss Lima.
- Thank you.
I have a little bit more
and you can edit out
whatever you don't wanna say.
- Let's hear it,
let's hear it, let's hear it.
- Okay.
First and foremost is that I spend about,
like five hours a day on the phone
trying to coordinate this stuff.
And I don't charge for my time.
And this is very
personally important to me
because I do believe
that it will help my
sisters in the long run,
but I've received a tremendous
amount of death threats.
Sorry, we're gonna have to retake this.
- [Mark] There's lots of death threats.
I get them too, and a lot of my--
- Yeah, but it's not, it's like.
- [Mark] Social media is
just this cancerous thing.
- Not even that.
I've had people look up my,
like try to find my address
and share my address.
I'm not crying on camera right now.
So it's like, if I was by myself,
if I didn't have a
family, I'll deal with it.
But the fact that like,
the GoFundMe campaign has not been doing,
it's been doing really amazing
in terms of we have 200 donors
that are super supportive,
but my husband and I
actually paid for Amanda's
first month of treatment
and we secured and we had to pay in cash.
So we took out a line of credit
and we tried to secure
at least the first two months for Amanda.
And it's not like we just
have money to blow around.
And I also have two sick sisters
that I'm responsible for.
And so for people to go, and as a startup,
anybody can can start a
business, a small business.
And so I don't get paid.
My team, I raised a small amount of money
from our seed round
and I use that money to
hire a team of people
to work with me.
And those people are very talented
and they could choose to
work for a bigger company
that could pay them more.
But they're so passionate
about what they're doing
that they're choosing to
be in the trenches with me
and make this happen and take pay cuts
and work way more hours
than they should be
because we're such a small team
to make all of this happen.
And my husband is taking
a huge financial risk
by helping me cover the costs.
And so to know that people
are trying to find my sisters,
or death threats about
my husband or my sisters,
or God forbid, like I travel
a lot, I fly to LA often
for what I'm doing with
Amanda and coordinating care,
which I personally
cover, the GoFundMe funds
go to giving and get paid
directly to hospitals.
So none of those expenses.
Larry and I--
- [Mark] If you look at the,
I mean, it's just the commenters.
'Cause the majority of the sentiment
towards what you're doing
is incredibly positive.
But there are some people
that like to cause problems.
And the death threats
that I've seen for me
and for a lot of the people I
interview, it's so disturbing.
I mean, it's like, I want to
just turn off the comments
permanently on my channel.
- Well, my Instagram messages,
I originally told everybody
that if they want to get a copy
of the LPS conservatorship templates
to message me on Instagram
because I wouldn't,
my clients email me so I would
never get back to people.
And so my Instagram messages
have been flooded with threats
and trying to find my sisters,
trying to find my husband,
and trying to share my address publicly.
And so those things are really scary
when you're going out of your way.
I'm not the best on film.
I know that there's a lot of things
that I need to work on
because my job is
actually behind a computer
or in a treatment center.
And so these are not things
that I'm like prepped and poised on,
but when it comes to me being on camera
and putting myself out there,
and then my family
getting the repercussions
where I've had to take down
my team page on my website
because some of my team
members were getting attacks.
And so to know that so
many people are taking
so many risks to work with
me and help build my vision.
And then those people get splattered on
because of something that I chose to do,
which is to publicly go out there
and try to be a part of this.
- [Mark] No, it's sad that
social media does this.
It's not you 'cause I've seen it many,
in many cases on my channel and it's sad.
I think a lot of people are
very disturbed out there.
- I will end on a very positive note
because I also did receive
some of the sweetest messages
from people asking, how is Amanda?
And can we send her
cards of encouragement?
- [Mark] And that's
really 99% of the reaction
to what you're doing.
But it's this 1% that causes problems
and it's disturbing.
- I've actually set up a PO box
and we can, I guess, link it down below.
And I've also put on
Instagram a tip for treatment,
like what to bring to treatment
and what to not bring to treatment.
So if people do want to send Amanda cards,
get well or encouragement or anything,
obviously there are certain
things that you cannot send.
And just so that everybody knows,
everything that is sent will be read
and screened through the facility.
So to be careful of what you write
or she will not receive it.
But I do think that that's
really gonna help her
because committing to a year
to completely change
your behavior patterns
and to change your life is a lot.
And to stay on track is a lot.
And so to know that she has the support,
not just from me and
Larry and Mark telling her
that so many people
are behind you on this,
but to actually get little
get well cards from people,
I think that that would
be an awesome touch.
'Cause she also won't have social media
in the treatment center.
- It's just sad to see
somebody who's doing something,
working so hard to do something so great
for somebody like Amanda
and getting that kind of negativity.
It's just, it's like,
what's the matter with us?
What's the matter with us?
Like who does that?
Who does that?
I don't even understand it.
But whatever, I think
you're an amazing person.
I recognized that before we
even shot our first video.
- Thank you so much.
- And you've been more than
I even imagined.
- More than that.
- And to everybody that's
been supportive of this,
I am just beyond grateful
because to be able to see like
all of the good that it's done,
and in court today when we saw Amanda
and how excited she is to know
that there's actually a change.
- [Mark] Yeah, you can
see that she was excited,
and in a real way, rather just
in a, can I get crack now?
- So you guys are responsible for that.
And to everyone that's
skeptical, that's great.
I say question everything.
If you're skeptical of
me and my intentions,
I hope that you let me
prove my intentions to you
in the long run.
But at the same time,
I don't think that there's ever any reason
to try to put somebody's life at risk.
And even if you think it's harmless,
it only takes one person to
show up at someone's house
or attack a family member,
my sisters, or my husband,
or whatever it may be.
So I just don't want to feel responsible
for putting anyone's life in danger.
- [Mark] Larry and I see
what you're doing firsthand,
very up close and it's it's
been unbelievable, right?
So positive.
So amazing.
So consistently thorough what
Lima has done for Amanda.
- Thank you so much.
- It's amazing to me.
- [Mark] I've never seen
another person like her.
- Thank you.
Well hopefully we're
gonna completely transform
mental health care together
and five years from now, we'll
all look back and be like,
I can't believe they used to
only do 30 days of treatment
and think that that would be okay.
- [Mark] All right, well
today was a great day.
- Excellent.
- And she gets out in 10 days.
- Yes.
- [Mark] And then is out for a year.
- Yes, and she will be
transferred directly
from the treatment center,
from the courthouse to
the treatment center
by the treatment center
or by the courthouse.
So there won't be any
possible intervening there.
- [Mark] Yeah, but she
did look great today.
She looked happy, healthy.
- She did.
- [Mark] Clear-headed and respectful.
And intelligent.
I mean, there was no
sign of the old Amanda.
If you hadn't told me that was Amanda,
I wouldn't have recognized her.
- [Larry] She was acting like my baby.
- [Mark] It was a beautiful day.
All right.
- All right.
- Thanks, you guys.
- Good stuff.
Mark, you're incredible.
- [Mark] We all are.
It's a nice little team we've got.
- [Larry] I'm gonna have to
roll for adjectives, man.
This young lady is something else.
- She really is.
- Thank you, guys.
- [Larry] She's real.
I'm gonna have to go by.